[Musique]
ils sont 18 ils ne se connaissent pas
mais ils ont rendez vous avec la
montagne architectes vignerons
infirmiers homme d'affaires mère de
famille aux artistes à première vue tout
les sépare
oh la la terrasse tout chignole réveil
surtout seul café
je sois moi on me la refuse
la frise le poison
alors françois lafond guide qui avait
couché avec moi ça de théophile et puis
oui louise ses bonnes chaussures ou bien
si on voulait faire des annonces au mans
j'ai toujours choisi isabelle dernière
on ne sait pas qui compte en tout petit
dans la ville c'est super on a un groupe
multi âges voilà un peu avec moi dans le
groupe
et puis je m'appelle séverine et puis d
autres sont là où on va peut-être
faire connaissance en il faut démarrer
la ceni du marcheur partagent le même
rail à terme en empruntant le légendaire
itinéraire bis jour de mai comme un pont
suspendu au dessus des zones alexandra
les chaussures sont est vraiment à ne
pas marcher la montagne elle son marché
voilà tous les montrer c'est de la folie
un sac comme ça c'est de la folie
après encore les crampons à mettre un
petit peu plus lourd alors tout le monde
mais qui peu à peu de mes gars alors
bonne journée on va déjà voir qu'est ce
qu'on a comme matériel la plupart
d'entre eux m'a supplié pour la première
fois à la hauteur
autant dire que des mots comme
baudrières piolets et crampons n'ont
jamais fait partie comme elle est
chassée choses donc il faut tous
d'accord voudriez leur est cher tout
tout tout à baudrières appris hier
c'est un non-choix ressasse à ses
demandes
on va tous sortir et en soirée ça c'est
drôle de l'autre celle des moulins
ça n'a l'air de rien mais faire son sac
et à l'art de ne pas confondre le
nécessaire flux ya toute ma garde robe
c'est mes culottes esprits moi je fais
me force pas enlever des choses mais
faudrait vraiment prendre le minimum
vital parce que c'est vous qui allez
souffrir à porter des poids qui sont pas
nécessaires nécessaire si beauté c'est
indispensable
c'est une excuse moi je me sente tenue
ça mais à côté ce qui a pas besoin de
changer de cap a un énorme plus son
propos les sharks les sharp abonnés des
charges voilà je peux répondre mais pour
un petit levé ce mode
alors tout ce qui est shampoing
maquillage crème de nuit
c'est dans la mâture petit sans
discussion voudrait-on non je le prends
moi quand tu as besoin tu m'appelles 1
mais ouais en fait comme ça
[Musique]
c'est à passer par
démarrage en douceur pour cette première
c'est le thème rempart de chamonix pour
rejoindre le break les manches pour
albert 1er mais dès le lendemain on
entrera dans le vif du sujet il refait
jamais en premier en france on va le
faire et en sus
[Musique]
ans
les dix-huit randonneurs sont répartis
en trois groupes
séverine l'aspirant guide elle conduit
le groupe qui s'est autoproclamé de
groupes plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hubert ce guide de 69 ans qui n'est pas
près de prendre sa retraite en a vu
d'autres son groupe a lui aussi choisi
son nom sur le groupe compétition
françois vient tout juste d'entamer sa
carrière de gris il se retrouve à la
tête du groupe le plus hétérogène nom de
code compagnie ils voyent 1.74 en
hommage à matteo 12 ans
voir
pas dégueu aller où
à chaud
[Applaudissements]
refuge albert 1er
c'est très long au bout de la mort m on
a toujours l'impression montagne c'est
pas trop loin mais ya encore deux heures
un peu près jamais lâché première fois
au total pas moins beau oui j'aime bien
faire des trucs que j'ai jamais faite
on a assez de souffle pour alimenter la
conversation mais les préoccupations
sont encore très urbaine
j'aime pas papy to be qu'il est pour moi
sont fait piquer une tête de porc
[Applaudissements]
exagère un peu peut-être de courage
aimerait bien voir sa tête de porc qui
c'est qui a vu la guerre des mondes
moi j'ai vu hier la grand-maman après
midi ouais je suis anéantie fils non
mais c'est loin d'être mehmedi dont
vient d'emménager du coup pas d'eau non
non non alors voilà on est parti pour
dix jours de vie commune ça passe ou ça
casse à ça ça va passer ça passe bien
pour l'instant on a dix jours pour sa
connaissance au chocolat il a dessiné un
peu pour mon métier chez architectes
voilà je dessine un peu mais on peut
envisager pas une petite de faire ce
type de dessin au calme
mais j'aime bien je trouve ça sympa je
trouve ça sympa ça je viens de genève
donc pas très loin d'ici je travaille
dans le domaine de la finance
j'avoue que ces monologues choses à
analyser dans quoi je me suis un peu
enviable au fur et à mesure prend le bus
ce matin depuis genève pour moi c'était
une première déjà agi assez génial mais
jamais peut-être bus puis c'est aussi le
challenge se retrouver que des gens
qu'on connaît pas la 1 doel et ça
m'intéresse j'ai fait pas mal de dos des
jeunes du cheveu éducateurs ont fait
quand même deux séjours vacances avec
déjà et là c'est bon mais c'est pour mon
plaisir personnel pashi maman je
travaille à temps partiel donc je cours
toute l'année donc mon but c'était aussi
de couper pour avoir du temps pour moi
moi je suis retraité va faire dix ans
ça c'est pour mieux dormir j'aime bien
aussi retraité de l'opéra de paris
classe 30e j'étais danseuse j'ai fait de
la danse classique aussi j'ai fait de la
danse classique
je sais encore faire le y/y ce que tu
avales rsa avec sage sage et lamerat
facile
[Musique]
chacun son style j'étais surpris on
libère les énergies ont débrayé les
chevaux sous le regard amusé des guides
qui ne tarde pas à découvrir à quel
genre de clientèle
ils ont fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
bon c'est bon vivre vous verrez ça va
pas marcher argerich à guitrozon toro
isabelle 39 ans je trouve que la vie n'a
pas de saveur sans s'exposer sans
prendre des risques et j'aimerais me
mesurer par rapport à cette aventure et
depuis donné le meilleur de moi-même je
m'appelle monique j'ai 65 ans j'avais
envie c'est la première fois et la
dernière de faire partie d'une cordée de
traverser un glacier c'est pas
raisonnable du tout c'est mon chant du
cygne si tu as une danseuse qui pence et
enrc body jours s'est offert un show
encore une bonne heure et en idées
non mais france le nez du mois
[Musique]
ça fait meilleur qui me dit encore 50 m
d'un mélange de croire ton équipe alors
tout le monde sera positif pour demain
après avoir tant à moi j'ai dit je suis
vite du repas très vite
mélangez j'ai dû très vite à du travail
c'était trop long effectivement j'ai pas
pu m'empêcher de tracé je suis une
grande partie de ces surtout ça et là je
n'étais pas dans mon rythme et ça m'a
beaucoup genia - je dis moi jusqu'au
bout j'ai dit à françois je passe devant
ou évasive mais tu nous attend
et puis c'est pas attendez voilà une
impatience qui se paye cash
première journée première embauche au
régime promiscuité pour ça pour le moins
relatif des retards pour l'un d'entre
eux c'est une découverte aussi super
cool
sans cette 1re classe i way
c'est bon on est tous une place alors on
écrit on la regarde que ceux de mon
groupe là puis la belle entrée dans un
coin sans citron chiens patous pression
moscou va pas dans les chambres voyons
origin fait attention de pas tous formés
regardez dans le même coin vous à faire
tomber si on commence à déballer les
cinq cas m à droite à gauche on est
sommelier quelque chose j'organise un
plus bio zéro mégot
le début de la liberté en temps pour
voir adam smith et même s'il a obtenu
non à rouler la garde d'enfants comme on
dit on va chercher la gauche qui a jeté
dans la bataille ses quatre et demi
quatre nuits douces conduisait pas non
quatre et demi on se lève c'est un peu
tard et près tout le monde dit que c'est
très tôt moi je sais plus quoi faire
face à l'attaqué 5 ha ça va tanguer sage
d'omaha situe qu'à trois unités des
jeunes et donc quoi on parle de sa
carabine survenu sur un coup de tête en
fait un peu envie de vivre un trip
particulier et puis il ya des attentes
qui sont énormes quand même je pense
mais ils m'ont fait d'ici aujourd'hui
finalement c'était quand même assez
court et on sait pas si quelqu'un a été
vite parce qu'il est il s'en est donné
ou mais demain on verra
des fois on a surpris un ce qui me donne
la mauvaise impression le premier jour
des fois c'est ce qu'on retrouve à la
voilà les masques tombent demain
[Musique]
le
bonjour moi des gens
[Musique]
c'est tout comme
c'est un sentiment chez pousser non mais
c'est vrai que j'ai même collé comme
pomme donc ouais j'suis sa femme ou moi
je dors plus à côté de toi c'est fini je
suis traumatisé lunettes la gourde
autres nations le ca qu il est prêt ils
auront du mal au genou histoire 6 heures
du matin dans un décor impériale qui
pour un peu passerait inaperçue nos
marcheurs ont d'autres préoccupations
ils font concrètement connaissance avec
la glace et le matériel technique autant
on fait des efforts extraordinaires en
technologies contemporaines pour des tas
de choses mais alors les crampons on a
vraiment rester à l'ère de la
préhistoire
bertrand sézanne une intervention
masculine alors que je crois je me suis
complètement mais les mains ces
compagnies et s'est rencontré au musée
pas sa venue que la 15 jours je vous
montrer comment sa tâche
c'est un médecin pour gagner du temps
tâchez de paris un contrat sur âge
ok alors là c'est vraiment mais attaché
un à la vie à la mort de marché on va
sur l'accord avec les crampons c'est
pour votre survie aussi hors d'usagé
comme un casse et les guides savent que
la journée sera longue
françois imprime dambé à s'accorder le
légendaire pas du tout la régularité de
cette marche n'a qu'un seul objectif
donner au groupe un minimum de cohésion
et lui apprendre à gérer son effort sur
plusieurs jours
trop admiration devant être régulier
ça va avancer ceux qui s'ennuient peut
admirer le paysage à des coûts d'admirer
le paysage certains marcheurs confondent
parfois vitesse et précipitation à
l'origine ce rythme ça se passe bien pas
assez rapide
régine ronge son frein
dès le départ elle a de la peine à
adapter sa fougue pour rythme de son
côté alexis pourtant plus la corde 1 on
a tous on a tous des fidèles sont là et
c'est vraiment la misère pour garder la
corse en dieu je n'ai pas entendu elle
sert à rien s'il ya quelqu'un qui tombe
dans une crevasse éthique la corde et
relâchez la safer un gros choc prend une
pomme 7 fera du bien soit 3,5 sur le
montage et au moins 2000 automne donc on
peut en fait cinq minutes de pause comme
on est à londres pour s'arrêter un peu
plus longtemps
on essaye quand même de marcher une
heure sans s'arrêter parce que si on
fait les poches a que 20 minutes clair
mat ce sera vraiment vraiment loin
[Musique]
avec le top
alors je te jeu l'animal doit être
augmenté de 14
aximum un tout petit en bas
[Musique]
la vallée rire tout le monde s'en sort
et eau
ces belles expériences de solidarité
savoir c'est transforme du marché en
même temps pour prendre le moins de
risques possibles
je suis accroché sans attendre à la
série les grandes philosophies sur la
vie après sportif neubois que l'accord
d'un résultat libéré après pour gambader
un peu à tournai zh c'est pas que je
n'aime pas la corde c'est que je suis
dans un groupe un peu l'un des leviers
des apc les voyages en hébreu mais qu'on
m'a pas beaucoup écouté voilà et
j'aimerais changer de compte
on avance un peu plus vite
le plus dur pour moi que j'ai découvert
ici c'est que derrière chaque montée est
sacrée descente et moi c'était les pires
moments c'est à chaque fois la descente
dès que vous
je suis contrôlé toutes les gammes
basit
dans cet esprit en cela la plupart on
n'est pas des montagnes 1 donc c'est
dans la difficulté qu'on resserre les
liens
en tout cas c'est plus intérieure de
fonctionner comme ça une entraide sans
savoir d'où l'on vient et qui ont les
surfaces sans problème
à temps
voilà à la lma
alain pilate le plateau mais de là à la
toile allié de mons
les toqués année là où l'expression et
où les genoux pour tout son sens la
motion avoir des rotules d'autres
circonstances
petit mode de masse et moi dire les
abricots de bienvenue au mercy vous
avouerez que c'est moi ça fait 11 heures
de marche moins deux jours deux pour
actes et yeux de dieu
ah si on m'avait dit ça ce matin tu as
aussi milieu entorse mais là ce n'est
longtemps c'était deux ans j'étais pas
là on a deux ans et encore un physique
comme ça que tu fais quoi rentrer je
souhaite le dire non je fais du tennis
du tennis il un peu plus tôt fig
on est tous très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'épuisement doit niveler vers le bas au
niveau de la prise de tête quand génial
tu fais pas des périphrases tc pas
d'expliquer des choses pour montrer la
lune dictionnaire tu va à l'essentiel
et puis c'est bon on y arrive tout soit
pile abbasi a des affinités sa part au
quart de tour
[Applaudissements]
il parle encore pour toute info je me
ferais tout le temps j'avais une énergie
que j'avais envie de déployer et là là
je craque qui comprend qu est-ce que moi
évidemment je suis la mère 2 alors ça je
n'ai pas mis quoi alors c'est ce qu'on
avait expliqué un peu comme on a un
groupe
oui on a bien vu que monique et paul
paul va peut-être un petit peu plus vite
mais monique elle ne peut pas aller plus
vite l'accord alors on était second plat
aujourd'hui fallait s'adapter au groupe
accor et pc de jouer un peu le jeu
difficile difficile
toujours est il qu'on verra comment ça
évolue ok et puis 14 sera plus haut à
partir de chariots on regarde comment ça
se passe
et puis on envisagera peut-être
changement pas d'accord sur tout on fait
des comme ça
il est un gars
c'est une forme virtuelle
[Musique]
fait connaissance les masques sont
tombés les premiers élan spontané de
solidarité cimente l'écho c'est le
moment de faire le plein plein d'énergie
la de souvenirs car zermatt est encore
loin
[Musique]
prochain épisode à la force du mollet où
l'on apprend qu'en montagne la ligne
droite mais pas forcément la plus courte
où l'on découvre qu'il n'y en a que le
poids du sac mais également celui des
habitudes
en gros ce sens au loup et petit coup de
pompe parcours fléché pour nos apprentis
marcheurs bienvenue au royaume de la
montagne
[Musique]